i hope the war goes on forever and ryan
gets drafted wait i'm sorry sorry i said
that i didn't
just part of me meant it
camp
just think that temp agency could have
sent you anywhere
i think about that all the time
see you tomorrow dwight
apparently
how's it going good day not now temp
um
okay
so um listen
i know about
your diabolical plan
what
diabolical plan i wouldn't even know how
to begin it uh
i found a copy of it in the copier tray
so what do you want
i want the same thing you want i want to
take jim halpert down
i want in
and just as you have planted your seed
in the ground
i am going to plant my seed in you
i think you know what you're saying
smells pretty bad doesn't it
uh-huh
it's called bull crap
and a client can smell it from a mile
away
gotcha oh hey i forgot something in my
car i'll be right back
okay
of course
bobcat this is dragon
listen he's been promoted to soul
manager we've got to step this up meet
me behind the dumpster in 90 seconds
89
58.
you're 20 minutes late
um
i was at another dumpster just admit you
lost track of time ryan and i have been
meeting up to work on our diabolical
plot against jim ryan is always late for
our meetings
i wish i had a lair
did you see saw of course i see saw mo's
and i see saw all the time no uh the
movie did you see the movie saw oh yeah
great film almost as fun as going on a
see-saw okay the reason these movies are
so popular is the element of
psychological torment
i like where you're going with this
continue
can we lure him into an old warehouse or
something i have an old barn it's kind
of smelly yes but that might be a plus
okay and then what we do what they did
and saw
i mean we don't kill him obviously i
have a mask okay that's your idea
exactly like in the movie
that is the most idiotic thing i've ever
heard in my life well suggest something
else then don't just supposed to cut his
leg off don't just criticize my idea you
think of something then
the new i.t guy
nick
nick i think he's the key he's very
trusting he's looking for friends he's
been given an awesome amount of power
and does not know how to wield it
like frodo
why don't you just let me handle the
tolkien references okay dumb jock
well i think he can be corrupted like
gollum
smeagol
was corrupted and became
gollum i might start a diabolical plot
against him after this one final
question
young ryan howard
what
is michael scott's
greatest fear
um loneliness
maybe women wrong
he's not afraid of anything
also i would have accepted snakes
fear is what it's all about you cannot
sell
while undergoing fear
you need to vanquish fear
one must wrestle beer
to the ground
you will now wrestle my cousin no okay
all right all right
okay no just no you're a freak i'm not
doing this
anymore over goodbye don't ryan you
don't have to wrestle him ryan
just get in the coffin
ryan
bye ryan
you seem
nice where are all the animals
ryan come on i am sorry i am sorry moses
sorry too look he sent over uh a basket
with eggs and some fat back bacon and
look something you whittled
i'm sorry you feel that way mr bart
uh is there anything i can do to make
things better
whoa give me the phone give me the phone
exactly that's my first complaint in 10
years things have been generally good
give me the phone tell them dwight
schrute wants to talk look uh mr bart
hey mr bart are these prices
right here you're not going to find this
anywhere else quite true here hey don't
hang out mr don't listen
stop flustering me everybody left this
boy on the phone ah mr bike
oh
i cannot believe you lost that account
he was my client for 10 years you made
him lose the account by screening at him
the entire time it's okay ryan you're
your secretary what do you know okay and
you're an attempt and i'm taking your
phone hey i'm confiscating guys you know
what i want you to do shake hands get
over it
that was not a shake dwight do you want
me to sing you a song my mother used to
sing me when we were sick
leave him alone it's a lullaby
ryan
right we're going to take your clothes
off no
guys
i think my friend troy might have a drug
problem
what do i do
i think his species might have a higher
tolerance than ours shh just
stop
here's what you do
you tell him that you're his friend and
that you're going to help him and that
everything's going to be all right
and then you put a wire on him
and you find out who's selling him drugs
and then you get that guy and you flip
up you turn him into a snitch you follow
that guy
it's the people who are really really
bad
been watching the wire recently i don't
understand a word of it guys i'm going
to sleep you can leave the light on if
you want but please stop talking okay
okay okay good night ryan
best night ever
brain teaser
i have two coins totaling 15 cents one
of them is not a nickel what are they a
diamond a nickel
no i said one of them is not a nickel
but the other one is i've heard that
before
okay
a man and a son get into a car accident
they are rushed to the hospital the
doctor says there's no way i can operate
on this boy because he's my son the
doctor is the boy's mother a man is
found hanging from the ceiling he
stepped on a block of ice hung himself
in the ice melted
hunter it's a polar bear because you're
at the north pole
right come on come on man why didn't you
go in there what everybody was scared
out of their way everyone okay
uh i have an announcement
apparently
in business school they don't teach you
how to operate a toaster oven
because some smart sexy temp left his
cheese pita
an oven instead of timing it for the
toaster thing
[Laughter]
wow
okay
well i guess they don't teach how to
operate a toaster oven in business
that's exactly what i said hey did you
miss that day there ryan were you
absolutely toast heaven 101 you failed
so sorry
hey i know it'll impress everybody i'll
start a fire
oh man bad idea bad idea jeans uh i have
it song attention everyone that i want
to sing that i wrote especially for this
occasion when i was up there among the
flames
ready
ryan started the fire
it was always burning since the world
returning ryan started the fire
it was always foreign
i can't help but think that something we
did made this possible jim dug his own
grave
but maybe we provided the shovel
oh temp i like that i'm gonna engrave
that into a piece of wood
care to celebrate with a drink
i would love
to why not no because martini bars are
pretentious
i'm sorry that i don't want farm boys
swell like you do you know it is not
farm boy swill i will show you it is
beat vodka and it is delicious i'm not
interested in anything i have to make
myself
you